you sound terrific
she sounds incredible yeah she sounds
absolutely incredible i mean you've been
through so much joanie yeah
i have
but but i i did it in good company you
know like my my nurses are with me yes
on this trip
and and my therapist
i've been surrounded by really good
people you know and it's been a happy
time my convalescence has it yeah it has
been it's been lovely how does it feel
to sing again oh it feels really good
she's playing guitar now yeah and she
plays the bongos and she hosts these
gems and she's brought this group of
young people together yeah that's ripple
affected
well beyond the jony jams well beyond
johnny's house you know we've well
brandy too you know is responsible for
that for you know because the
generations are always kind of a part
like when when when paul mccartney came
to one of our jobs and he said
it was great to be surrounded by a young
up-and-coming musician that wasn't
something he'd experienced you know
so the generations kind of stay apart
but
thanks to brandy you know i'm included
in you know my my blue album went to
number one
50 years after its release hey
johnny
hey
you've gotten
it you've got an incredible accolades
this year the kennedy center honors the
music cares honoree yeah yes bring it
how did that feel
oh very rewarding you know because for
you know
a lot of doors were shut to me like the
rock and roll hall of fame they kept me
out of that for a long time so you're
feeling the love
i'm feeling the love yeah it's very
rewarding it feels good it feels good
it's a beautiful thing to see you're
honored in this way yeah brandi
mentioned
you're playing
guitar you taught yourself to play again
i'm learning i i'm looking at videos
that are on the net to see what where i
put my fingers you know
it's amazing like what an aneurysm
knocks out
how to get out of a chair you don't know
how to get out of the bed you don't know
how yeah you know we have to learn all
these things by road again you know i
was a i was into water valley as a kid
and
i forgot how to do the breaststroke
every time i try to i just go drown you
know
so there's a lot of you going back to
infancy almost you have to relearn
everything how do you find the will to
do that
i don't know but the
the surgeon uh duckwill that that did
did the brain surgery on me i said i had
will and grit yeah you show that every
day do you think do you think you have
will and grit yeah i think they do
she definitely does
i've recovered from a lot of things you
know you sure have polio yes you know
your friends call you a miracle
[Laughter]
yeah and and i you know i didn't get
downhearted by it and i was surrounded
by really good people and we laughed and
yeah and they made my convalescence very
pleasant
and i've never heard anybody call
convalescence pleasant
it is if you have good company yes
it's great to hear and now she's about
to headline newport i know
78.
you've been you've been thinking about
this for quite a while
i dreamed it the first time she opened
her mouth
and sang summertime
and i saw
herbie hancock burst into tears
and everybody in the room catch their
breath because she had decided to sing
really decided to sing you know
um
i knew
i knew she'd do it on newport
i can't really say how i knew it i just
pictured her out there i pictured the
water and the fort and the boats yeah
and everybody just
was so happy to be with her in that way
twice before yeah 67 yeah and 69. yeah
yeah i met leonard cohen and 67 i met
james taylor in 69 yeah that's pretty
good company good friends for my life
yeah yeah
what are you expecting from the audience
in here in
don't
newport
don't think that way you don't i don't
have
expectations but
you know i think it'll be warm if it's
it's been warm every place i've been
recently i mean i think
i think coming having a brush with death
like that kind of softens people towards
me
i think that she um
has always changed the world through
music yes and now she's changing the
world through music by
causing young people to congregate
around her yeah
and raise the bar on each other and on
the sense of community and what we're
doing is we're giving the audience a
gift because they're going to get a
glimpse at that they're going to get a
glimpse at the way that jenny mitchell
is still impacting changing the world
through pop culture right this very
minute
right and
you know what the audience is going to
be i know what they're going to do
and i thought i was going to be horrible
but i wasn't too horrible tonight
are you at all nervous about singing in
front of an audience again no i've never
been nervous about being a caring
audience but i wanted to be good you
know and i wasn't sure that i could be
but i didn't sound too bad to me
thank you both so much thank you anthony
it's such a treat